we are here with lily and zach maggio
and um they have come to us with a
design dilemma for their bedroom we
heard their story
um i'm very nervous right now because
i uh i just hope you like it i'm sure
we'll love it okay we'll let's see um
all right this is what your bedroom
looks like now uh-huh yeah are you ready
yes all right let's see
[Music]
it wow
it looks great
i love it
come on in guys
[Music]
[Applause]
um
so i'm crying again
thank you
it's so pretty
yeah it's wonderful oh god thank god
[Applause]
and actually one of the first states
that we ever went we went on a hike you
said you took out your camera yeah
it's like you knew
okay good
um i did something that i don't normally
do was i tried to design a lot for you
zach um i have a little game area so
that you guys can like chill and have a
glass of wine and play some backgammon
and be like do we want to talk about
kids or not talk about kids
um here is where i have an example of
the pops of black that have been
inspiring me in design i thought i would
bring it in
with whether it's the hardware of the
lamp or the material
of
the poof or the frames and the
photography that's also something that
i've never done on the show was bring a
lot of photography
because i thought that in your bedroom
which has nothing on the walls right now
um that you could stare into photographs
um that were a little sexy
and a little mysterious and weren't so
obvious and had a touch of sort of an
androgynous approach so that it could
speak
to you
and i thought you know you don't need a
frilly bedroom
honestly
um what you guys need is a sexy suite to
escape to thank you very much um it's
incredible it really is
it's wonderful it's so cool i wanted to
bring in some woven a nice sort of like
hide rug
um a really this bed detail actually
really look how beautiful this is oh
headboards are always hidden by pillows
nobody thinks about that but
so when your pillows are down you have a
nice headboard that has like a nice
woven touch but it's pretty with the
pillows and without i kind of was
inspired by amber tones
to go with the black and i thought you
know what i would love if you guys would
come into your bedroom and feel like you
were in a sexy almost hotel that you
owned
i can totally see you and like yeah i
see it it's so cool
and i love it i also got you guys this
mirror which i really loved because it's
just
the yin and yang that make that full
circle which is really
you know who you guys are and for you
so
what do you think
it's so cool
thank you so much that's great
fantastic thank you i'm like stopping
myself from like seeing what a real
bed's like again
i probably may not be able to kill
that's fine you don't have to it's your
bed now this is the unusual side i want
to say thank you to our
our design team because we just i mean
we literally placed every piece of art
and every piece of furniture and built
mood board after mood board and
we were like oh we bought all all this
art and like put it up and we were like
it's not enough
more
everything in here every single thread
and detail it is all yours it's going
home with you obviously thank you thank
you so much um
and
thank you so much light your candles and
enjoy your new bedroom oh thank you like
i could totally hug you why not
thank you so much
oh this is so nice
thank you roots
i love the town
thank you lily and zach truly
[Music]